bailar no solo bailar
no bailar es mostrarle al mundo lo que
somos la manera en la que pensamos
la manera como nos relacionamos nuestros
valores más profundos
bailar es explorar hasta conquistar nos
es encarnar tu identidad en el mundo
bailar en pareja es
seguir para las mujeres y llevar para
los hombres
encarnar un rol de género hiper formarlo
de una manera suficientemente
convincente
la primera vez que fui a una clase de
tango asumí que yo debería hacer el rol
de ser y la verdad es que me acomodé a
ello porque pensé que así sería más
fácil
estuve siguiendo durante unas semanas
y cuando tuve suficiente confianza en mi
cuerpo empecé también a hacer los pasos
que el profesor les enseñaba a los
chicos
pero un par de semanas después mi
profesor se acercó a mí y me dijo
no quiero que límites más los pasos de
los varones en clase
yo le pregunté porque él y entonces él
me dijo que es que entorpecía el ritmo
de la clase
yo le dije que eso no era cierto que si
hacía falta yo podía hacerlo el doble de
rápido que el resto
esa no es la verdadera razón le dije
porque no quieres que llegue y entonces
él se ha ido frente a mí y gritó por qué
no
bailar
es político
aquel suceso realmente me hizo
reflexionar
claramente en mi cuerpo no había nada
que me impidiera llevar yo quería
hacerlo y estaba pagando mis clases pero
para mi profesor como para otras muchas
personas en el mundo del tango eso no
era tan malo
aquel día realmente descubrí el
verdadero significado de la expresión y
texto total
parecía que el tango por sí solo no
bastaba no era suficiente eran más
importantes estas relaciones de poder
que ocultaba
parece que se basa en esa fantasía de
belleza en la cual un hombre lleva una
mujer y juntos forman esta pareja
perfectamente complementaria pero debajo
de la belleza de esa fantasía se esconde
una estructura de poder que es impuesta
en el baile del tango hay dos roles
perfectamente diferenciados
no hay coreografía es un baile
improvisado el tango social está el rol
de seguir
y el rol de llevar bailemos un poquito
para verlo
[Música]
bueno este es el tango
s
el tango tradicional normalmente suele
decirse que manda el hombre y la mujer
obedece pero habéis visto semejante
demostración de autoridad a una persona
que estaba mandando ya otra que estaba
obedeciendo
no claro
en nuestra sociedad patriarcal tampoco
es que los hombres gobiernen en todas
circunstancias sobre las mujeres
pues en el tango igual
cómo sería el tango si realmente se
desnudase y nos mostrase con descaro
esas estructuras de poder veámoslo
[Música]
el tango
y
el tango no sería muy estético verdad se
vería incluso algo ridículo y es que
toda técnica implica una fluidez y una
sutilidad que son impropias de una
estructura zafia como mandar y obedecer
hay otra versión más light que dice que
la persona que lleva invita y la persona
que sigue interpreta veámoslo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
funciona no se ve tan violento como lo
anterior la persona que lleva está
escuchando las posibilidades de la
persona que sigue y la persona que sigue
no se siente directamente violentada
o suena esto se parece un poquito más a
la estructura de poder patriarcal
presente en nuestra sociedad no es que
los hombres de manera pública y
flagrante tengan el dominio y el control
sobre las mujeres pero los valores los
valores patriarcales imperan y las
mujeres están sujetas a una estructura
que muchas veces pueden ni siquiera
llegar a ver
es una estructura de poder más sutil
pero sigue ahí
y esto significa que cuando bailamos
dentro de esta estructura y de sus roles
estamos reproduciendo una realidad en la
cual los varones y las mujeres no son
iguales
hace
más de 10 años que me dedico a dar
clases de tango
y me sigue sorprendiendo lo mucho que
mis alumnas y alumnos saben de tango el
primer día que llegan a clase todas las
mujeres saben que van a salir todos los
varones saben que van a llegar
sabéis siempre me he preguntado
porque mis alumnos desean este tipo de
relación porque no llegan a las clases
deseando aprender los dos roles retar
los dos roles e incluso reinventar los
y con los años me he dado cuenta de que
lo que pasa es que encarnar tu rol de
género comporta un reconocimiento social
en otras palabras el placer también es
político y nos venga a los ojos ante las
estructuras patriarcales del poder
esto no significa que disfrutar de
bailar los roles nos convierta de manera
individual en malas personas en hombres
dominantes o en mujeres sumisas es el
sistema el que se reproduce a través de
la práctica de estos roles y de otras
muchas prácticas
tras cientos de milongas y de clases
me da cuenta de una cosa bailar no suelo
bailar cuando bailamos le damos forma al
mundo a nuestro mundo a las relaciones a
nuestras relaciones
nuestro deseo está conectado con esa
identidad que construimos a través de
las prácticas y el baile nos permite
visibilizar lo afortunadamente las
estructuras de poder en las que bailamos
son creadas por las personas y si nos
hemos acostumbrado a bailar en roles
subalternos a no escuchar oa no
escucharnos oa no aprovecharnos hasta
nuestro máximo potencial entonces las
personas podemos y debemos cambiar esas
estructuras
y cómo hacerlo bien podemos empezar
cuestionando ese deseo que nos hace
querer vivir y bailar bajo limitaciones
sobre lo que podemos ser o sobre lo que
debemos hacer
todo empieza por sospechar del deseo y
si lo hacemos estaremos más cerca de
bailar de desear y de vivir mejor
desde que empecé a bailar tango siempre
pensé que si no hubiera roles entonces
tampoco habría esas estructuras
y que bailando estaríamos cambiando el
mundo a mejor
descubrí una danza que no trata de
definirte que no juega con nuestras
opresiones históricas ni la reproduce
sino que nos libera de ellas a cada paso
el tango queer
una danza que no acata códigos
patriarcales y que pasa del qué dirán
que disuelve los roles de género en el
baile y también trasciende el machismo
del mundo del tango donde aprendemos
todo el tango y no solo una mitad
donde nos expandimos para luchar contra
las opresiones de género de clase de
raza donde el activismo se ejerce al
bailar y donde bailando empatizamos
porque aprendemos el rol de llevar y
también aprendemos el rol de seguir
y si queremos los intercambiamos y los
disolvemos totalmente porque podemos
porque queremos y porque al hacerlo
demostramos que esos roles ese mito no
eran necesarios en un primer lugar
sola
[Aplausos]
[Música]
o no
o
vuelvo a escuchar
vuelves en el adiós y el remolino con
risa y mi rencor y tu reír y mi dolor
y todo mi amor
[Música]
a
el tango queer
es un espacio para la diversión y para
la técnica sí pero sobre todo es un
espacio de democracia de consenso
de práctica política a través del cuerpo
y sabéis para muchas personas este tango
ya es el único tango
en el lo que ocurre es fuera de la pista
es tan importante como lo que ocurre
dentro
el discurso y las relaciones de género
que se crean que nos retan que nos
sacuden que nos amplifican y que llegan
por fin a todas las personas porque
capturan la oportunidad de recuperar lo
social lo popular del tango el tango el
tango nació del puerto de la migración
de la marginalidad del cruce de gentes y
de culturas del deseo de la ilusión por
construir un futuro mejor
el tango queer crea un espacio donde ser
valientes y vulnerables en colectivo
os imagináis un mundo en el que siempre
bailaremos así yo sí en ese mundo
el tango sería una danza popular de
verdad y queer sería un espacio en el
que redefinir el poder y ccoo crearlo un
espacio en el que compartir el poder
nuestro poder
en ese espacio bailar bien no dependería
de cuánto impresionamos a la audiencia o
cuánto nos adaptamos a roles socialmente
aceptados sino de cuánto nos sentimos
cuánto nos escuchamos y cuánto nos
cuidamos
no sería genial que eso fuese lo que nos
impresiona en los demás
por eso hoy aquí y ahora te invito a que
busques oa qué crees una comunidad una
comunidad de tango queer en tu ciudad y
que lo hagas desde una voluntad
auténtica de transformación más allá de
etiquetas y de roles de lo correcto y de
lo esperado te invito a que escuches y
respetes a que te escuche si te respeten
ya que tu cuerpo se acude a tu mente
hasta que cualquier injusticia por sexo
género raza clase se caiga al suelo
creando y abriendo un mundo de
posibilidades de identidades y lo más
importante de todo de solidaridad
espero que baile es consciente activista
y libre por todas esas personas que
quieren pero aún no se atreven espero
hasta que tú ya no esperes hasta que te
bailes y nos bailes hasta cambiar el
mundo entero muchas gracias
suena
[Aplausos]
o no
escuchar
vuelves en el adiós y el remolino con
risa y mi rencor y tu reír y mi dolor
y todos
[Música]
[Aplausos]